So we have a panic situation happening.
But Joe Biden is putting out proposals which
we've already talked about on the other side.
Donald Trump has replaced his campaign manager,
Brad Parr, scale with only three and a half
months to
go in the campaign.
Now, Donald Trump is framing this as this
is great.
I'm doing this because it's just also wonderful.
I'm going to show you in a moment how Donald
Trump is presenting this change.
But make no mistake.
Don't be confused.
You only replace your campaign manager.
Three and a half months before the election.
If you're panicking and things are going terribly
and I'll actually give you an example in a
moment of the last time a sitting president
replaced their campaign manager three and
a half months before the election.
Now, to back up a little bit, rumors have
been swirling about Donald Trump being furious
with his campaign manager, Brad Parr, scale
for a while.
I think it was about two months ago when the
polling started to go south for Trump.
There were leaks from the White House that
on a Friday night,
Donald Trump was in the Oval Office on the
phone with Brad Parr scale screaming at him.
And I'm paraphrasing here saying how the FMI
losing to Joe Biden.
And it's been downhill from there, both in
terms of the virus and Trump's polling.
And now Brad Paşa Scale is out formally.
They're calling this just a reorganization.
As usual, Trump is trying to put a.
Positive spin on everything he does, tweeting
last night around 9:00 p.m..
That, quote, I am pleased to announce that
Bill Stepien has been promoted to the role
of Trump campaign manager Brad Paşa Scale,
who has been with me for a very long time
and has led our tremendous digital and data
strategies, will remain in that role while
being a senior adviser to the campaign.
Both were heavily involved in our historic
2016 win, and I look forward to having a big
and very important second win together.
This one should be a lot easier as our poll
numbers are rising fast.
That's not true.
The economy is getting better.
Vaccines and therapeutics will soon be on
the way.
And Americans want safe streets and communities.
So let me interpret for you.
Trump realizes straightup firing his campaign
manager would look very, very bad.
So instead, he says, hey, we're just going
to shift things around bread.
Pass scale is not gonna be campaign manager
anymore.
But he'll keep doing digital stuff because
he's so good there.
But we're putting in place a different campaign
manager.
But everything's great and everything's hunky
dory.
This is a firing and you're file it firing
someone who has failed, but you're finding
a way to do it.
That maybe doesn't look as panicked.
And the reality is Trump should be panicked
because his approval is
down a 36 percent in the latest Quinnipiac
poll.
We'll talk about that later.
One thousand Corona virus deaths in the United
States yesterday for the first time since
June 9th.
So it's been five weeks since the U.S. had
a thousand corona virus deaths in a day.
We had it yesterday.
It's tragic.
Other countries have figured it out.
This is unnecessary loss of life.
And a new poll out yesterday shows that 62
percent of Americans believe that Donald Trump
is actually hurting the Corona virus response
rather than being a force for good when it
comes to the Corona virus response.
Our friend Bill Share pointed out to me on
Twitter this morning that the last time a
sitting president I know that in 2016, in
the summer, Trump changed campaign managers.
But now I'm talking about the last time a
sitting president who is running for
reelection replaced their camp campaign manager.
This late in the game was in 1992, when George
H.W. Bush, Bush 41, replaced his campaign
manager in the summer.
We know how that turned out.
Bush 41 lost to Bill Clinton just a few months
later.
And importantly, we also haven't had an incumbent
president who was this far behind in the polls
three and a half months before an election
since 1992 either.
Now, in terms of the actual staff change in
the strategy here from Donald Trump, I don't
know what part Scale's replacement, Bill Stepien,
is going to be able to do right now.
Remember that Stepien was the guy fired by
former New Jersey Governor Chris Christie
in that entire Bridgegate debacle.
That's a different story.
But if Stepien was too incompetent for Chris
Christie, I don't know how he helps Donald
Trump.
Stepien is good friends with
Jared Kushner.
There's speculation that that's really what
this is maybe about.
Hilariously, remember that Trump claims that
all of the polls that have him losing are
fakes, suppression polls.
And he actually tweeted he's going up in the
polls.
If that's the case, if you believe you're
winning, why would you take out of power your
campaign manager who has you winning?
It's because Trump knows that he's in trouble.
And I actually don't think that Brad Parr
scale is the problem.
I don't think PA scale is a particularly good
campaign manager.
He is a good data and analytics guy.
But the problem is not strategy here.
The problem is that Trump has failed on Corona
virus and everything else that has gone on.
And again, the easiest way to win this election
for Trump would have been in January and February
to start properly handling coronavirus from
the beginning.
It literally takes months to get outbreaks
under control.
Time is running out, right?
We're in mid July and Texas is peaking.
Florida's I mean, peaking.
They're going up.
They may not even if peak yet, it takes eight
to 10 weeks to flatten the cases and then
an additional 20 days to flatten deaths.
We're at Election Day.
Right.
Understand that the timeline is if all these
states did everything perfectly starting today,
we are at Election Day before the numbers
really get under control.
And so all Trump has left is dirty tricks.
Remember that.
Understand that.
Let me know where you are on this.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
We had I know I told you this last week and
I told you this the day, the week before and
the week before yesterday.
Wednesday was the best day ever for the David
Pakman
show, YouTube channel and the David Pakman
Show audio podcast.
You go back to the beginning of the show.
Yesterday was the best day on both of those
platforms.
And just a reminder, if you like, consuming
the show in a longer form format.
Get the audio podcast for free on Stitcher.
Google Play I.
ITunes, Pandora, Spotify.
Hi, et cetera, et cetera.
Wherever you prefer, we'll take a quick break
and be back after the The David Pakman Show
David Pakman
dot com.